Hey YouTubers it's Charlie! Time to start
your game of thrones therapy session that's
right our watch begins now like the long watch
till season six starts. Every year it always
feels like the finales try to accomplish something
a little bit different I mean is really all
about paying off the storylines that they
set up this season the extra bonus though
is that we get to pay off some storylines
from way way back like all the way back to
Renly and Stannis. So just careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen the episode yet in case
you haven't seen it yet and new round of the
giveaway starts now I'm giving away a signed
copy of a feast for crows signed by George
RR Martin all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and leave a comment on this video.
So here we go, Stannis' sacrifice starts to turn
sour this is like the beginning of his worst day
ever. Seriously, when Melisandre started to
hear about all the bad things that were happening
it was just one thing right after the other.
Half this all  the sellswords have left. They took their
horses with them. What's that? You have some
more bad news? Well, it couldn't be any worse than
half my men leaving. Oh wait, no! My wife just
hung herself. A lot of this gets into Melisandre
misinterpreting her visions which she's known
to do. We have to jump to the Arya storyline
real quick as I think this is really important
line that's relevant to what's going on with
Melisandre. Jaqen says that only death can
pay for life what does that mean in the context
of Stannis and Melisandre? May be the gift that
the Red God is giving is something that they
just haven't seen yet. It's not like ordering
something off of Amazon. I mean its not like you
sacrifice your daughter and you get the printer
you want in the mail. When Jaqen says a debt
is owed, that works two ways so that also ties
in with potential Jon Snow storylines. So even
though it looks like Melisandre is getting
ready to cry she still might get some great
gift from the red God. If there is anything you can
say about Stannis is that he is committed.
Like he sees the Boltons riding on them he
still pulls his sword. Onto number nine. Samwell
wants to go to Oldtown this is a storyline
that's right out of the books and we really are
like you know right where the story in the
book sends Samwell goes to Oldtown to learn
to become a Maester with Gilly and the baby
the only changes is that Maester Aemon went
with them and died on the journey. So just
a minor change there he died at the wall instead
of dying on the way there there actually already
scouting locations for game of thrones season
six and it looks like one of the locations
that they've found is something that could
be Oldtown Samwell speech just confirms that
the only thing I took issue with was when
Samwell said watching Gilly and the baby die
would be worse than 1000 white walkers. And I
was like, wow, hold up you did not see episode
eight white walkers are way worse than anything
except maybe getting stabbed by Arya thousand
times onto number eight Breinne finally kills
Stannis he's such a big character that they
had to let them go out like a warrior so that's
that's why they let them kill those two Boltons
soldiers but there was no way he was going
to survive that's where they should all that
blood flowing out from him whenever the camera
panned up though it and revealed that it was
Brienne I felt like it could've been anybody
I didn't know they would actually let her
kill him in the finale you can't say the
show doesn't pay big plot points off it is
a big change in the books but Brienne is
in a completely different place when this
is going on. The battle for Winterfell is
like a 'Winds of Winter' thing so we don't know
how it's going to play out in the book it
might go the same way it was such a satisfying
moment I totally do not have any issues with
any of the changes they made onto number seven
the Arya shows mercy to Meryn Trant now confirmed
pedophile who else feels like him whipping
all those little girls was just like a little
much and then he gut punched the girl that
Arya was pretending to be really anything
he would've done with any of those girls would've
been super creepy because they are like really
little girls but this is going into like torture
porn area can you imagine what he's done that
he hasn't been caught for like what is he
do when he is back in Kings Landing they just
wanted to make that Arya payoff seem that
much sweeter but I feel like it it was so
extreme that it became abstract but even given
all the ice zombies that we've seen you know
air quotes I feel like this is the closest
game of thrones will get to a slasher flick
the crazies with pan in that moment though
is watching Arya go from this unit stab the
little girl likes slicing his throat say who
are you you are no one then on a dime turning
into this scared little girl like oh my God
I can't see. Onto number six Arya loses her
sight. Also really big book moment. In the books
Arya kills someone if I mean it's a different
person but she still kills someone she's not
supposed to then she wakes up the next morning
and she can't see. The extra parts that they
added on, was the magic with the faces of
the faith. The faceless men do practice a certain
amount of sorcery when they're changing faces. There's like a magical component to it, so you confused
as to what you know like why she kept pulling
all those faces off till she saw her own she wasn't
hallucinating she did't get poisoned or anything
like that. That was happening in real life
like right in front of her eyes. it's part
of the faces men's magic that she hasn't learned
yet. one of the hardest things to judge is
like that is the timeline like how long between
episode one in episode 10 has it been? really
I think it's been a couple months. Cercei
gets stuck in the black cells for a while
so I think that's a better benchmark. onto
number five though. Sansa and Reek escape minor
disappointment with this storyline. Sansa
does show some courage like she's she's ready
to walk into the face of death but Reek is
the person who gets the kill. I understand he's
on a redemption arc so it was pretty likely that
he was going to save Sansa in some way but
it would've been nice to see Sansa stab Myranda
like say with the barrel opener that she
used to pick the lock. Usually people complain
when a character gets killed off but I think
in the case of Sansa people will be more upset
that she didn't kill a bunch of characters
off it's just one of those storylines that is
vastly changed from the books because they
actually they run into Stannis's army in the
books before Stannis marches on Winterfell.
So now were like work completely new territory.
That being said now that they're on the run
I feel like it's a good opportunity for Sansa
to step up because Reek can barely function
as a human being he can barely speak in full
sentences. Onto number four, Ellaria Sand poisons
Myrcella. This is one of the better rug pulling
moments in the episode because they have this
really nice moment she finally says I know
I totally know about you and mom I'm so happy
that you're my dad and then bam she looks
like she's dead I can't say that I'm super
close to the Myrcella character but I'm really
interested in the twist that this is going
to open up in the sand snake plot. Because
think about it, Trystane's on the boat, he loved
Myrcella he is going to be pissed. He's going
to tell his father Prince Doran was going
to be pissed at the sand snake's. Ellaria did
swear fealty to Prince Doran. I mean she was
she's weeping openly at his feet. You could
argue that he told her to poison Myrcella
but he was so open about not killing little
girls so I don't think that's the case. I think she went rogue. We also have to remember that final
moment with Bronn in Tyene sand or she is like, maybe you'll see me sooner rather than
later that's probably going to be the Sand Snakes in season six that's another one of
those storylines they changed the whole bunch
so we could see sand snake showing up in places
that they show up in the books or they could
completely change it. They definitely made
hanging plotline's like you know slam to Black
a big thing in this episode were it's like
they give you the like that oh my God reaction
and then it just gone. Like you have to wait
till season six to find out what's going to
happen. Onto number three. Daenerys gets captured
by the Khalasar. I totally love Daenerys
and Drogon, like he's very clearly licking
his wounds and super tired but he's just like
his like a little puppy who just shakes Daenerys off.
Its like, 'I am tired, go away mom.' They want
you to feel like he's incapacitated so Daenerys
is on her own. He's not to save her from the
Khalasar. They did a good job of like feeding
us information though you know she drops that
engagement ring at the gets Hizdahr's engagement
ring so that Daario and Jorah will be able to find it and they can track her down if
you're confused about why that circle of horses
started growing or growing around her that's
just a battle technique to keep her from escaping.
The Khalasar itself is actually made up
of a bunch of people that used to belong to
Khal Drogo's Khaalsar. When he died a bunch
of other Khals rushed in to fill the vacuum
so the Khal that found Daenerys is just like
the next biggest one after Khal Drogo. And I
know people get really worried about Daenerys
but she has this thing whereby she finds herself
in shady situations and completely turns them
around. So do not expect the worst. We also have to give a big shout out to Varys who is now with
Tyrion. Try not to burn down Meereen while we're
away. Seriously now you have two bros in Meereen
Varys and Tyrion, and then you have two bros
on a road trip Jorah and Daario. That's probably
going to be one of the funniest things next
season: Torah and Daario. Varys said this really
awesome line to where he said it's a grand
old city choking on violence and deceit. If
only you had some experience with something
like that he was obviously talking about King's
Landing also a grand old city choking on violence
and deceit. The funny thing about Varys though
is that he just comes out of nowhere. He's like the Terminator, like the T 1000. He just
slowly comes out of the wall like you didn't
even see him there. Onto number two though.
Cersei's walk of shame also right out of the
books. They do really good job of showing you
just how far she has to walk from Baelor's sept
to the Red Keep is a long freaking way. There's
no way you guys would've been able to tell
this, but if you're following like all of the behind-the-scenes
production. There was this big controversy about the
city where they film that not allowing them
to do a naked walk through the streets with
the production ended up doing is using a naked
body double for Cersei because she has like
a no nudity clause in her contract and then
shooting the rest of her whenever she was
like shoulders up. so they didn't have to use a
lot of CG to combine her head with the other
body. It's just like if you got excited about
watching Cersei naked you're not actually
looking at Cersei naked. That's another actress
with Lena Headey's head on her body. It's totally
okay, we will not judge you here for getting
excited about Cersei walking naked through
the streets. I really started to absorb her
emotions as she was walking the streets that
she slowly starts to break down people shouting
at her like that Nun ringing the bell once
it started spitting on her throwing trash
I had to look away for you know for just a
second because it was pretty terrible but
even is much as it seems like she's completely
lost it she's just completely broken
down. She bloodied she's covered in filth, the
minute she hits the main gate of the Red Keep
is when she just completely breaks as a human
being. I was a little upset when they took
it right back by introducing Robert Strong
like right away. Seriously you have her at her
lowest point. She almost has this religious experience,
an actual legitimate religious experience
as she walks through the doors and then they take
it all back it's like she's completely 180'd
back to terrible person when she sees this
big strong person to kill all of her enemies.
And no, they do not know anything about Robert
Strong about Qyburn's science experiment which
is definitely the Mountain with necrotic tissue
you can actually see it between his eyeholes
don't forget though Cersei still has her trial
with the faith so that's clearly going to
be a season six thing. And finally no surprise
here, by number one WTF moment for the watch
Jon Snow gets stabbed and left for dead all
the show people know exactly how the book
readers have felt since 2011. Seriously this
moment has been around for the last four years
with fans trying to figure out how Jon Snow
might be able to survive it and you would
be correct if you assume there are a couple
tinfoil theories. The most legit being that
Melisandre is going to resurrect him. Which
I think is going to be the case. The other
possibility being that he works into ghost
or somehow he gets turned into a white walker.
Really it takes you back to when Ned Stark
was killed that the main hero or who you thought
the main hero was was getting killed off . Everybody
just remember though Samwell said very clearly
to Olly don't worry Jon always comes back. That's a very important line: Jon always comes back.
The really similar cliffhanger to this
like that you know is he dead is he not take
cliffhanger was back from episode four were
we didn't know about Barristan Selmy and gray
were made we didn't find out who was alive
and who is dead till the next episode. The
problem with this moment though is that it
is like very much a book 5 cliffhanger so
the books won't tell us whether or not John's alive till Winds of Winter which is at least
a year away. I feel like people would've been
screaming no matter what Dan and Dave did
but I feel like not letting us know what happened to
Jon is the smart decision. I have a question
for you guys. Do you feel like Dan and Dave
did the right thing and not telling us what's
going to happen to Jon Snow and how do you
think that he's going to come back?
I'm also thinking about all the people that were so
bummed that Benjen didn't show up in the episode.
Seriously that early recap of pension posted
and people had so many theories I try to stay
away from it because I sought so late. There was the IMDb post saying that Benjen
was going to be in the episode. Generally I just learnt not to trust IMDb and I feel like
they didn't need to put Benjin in the recap
I think the reason they did is because it
been so long since the name Benjen had been
said out loud on the show. Those of you that
are still really upset about Shireen especially
since it seemed to amount to nothing. Just
remember that death has to pay for life so I
think that life is going to manifest in the
form of Jon Snow coming back. Now that we've
had the finale what's going to happen is tomorrow
I'm going to post my season six predictions.
I'm going to do an extra giveaway I'm doing the
book giveaway in this video but tomorrow will be
be an extra giveaway in my predictions video
and I'll announce the winners of both of those
in the Q&A video that should also post Monday
night or at least by Tuesday morning and by
the time those drop I should have an idea
of what my next bonus videos going to be. But
I will do a bonus video later this week I'm
not I'm not to wait a full week to do another
bonus video. If you have any requests just
leave them in the comments. For those of you that
really want me to do like a rating for this
finale relative to the other finales you know
what I'll say is all say thumbs down for Sansa.
Thumbs up for long payoffs and some of the
really good cliffhangers and another thumbs
down for that final Cersei moment. Exciting
to see Robert strong but really upsetting
to see that her character didn't learn anything
from that experience other than she should have
killed more enemies even faster. If you want
to give the episode thumbs up for anything
though I would give it a thumbs up for thematic
consistency. So we opened with Stannis is very
bad to worse day that's kind of a metaphor
for the entire episode and was going to happen
in episode one of season six. Like you think
things can't get any worse and then all of
a sudden they do. We have not hit rock bottom
yet. So if you guys haven't seen it earlier today,
I posted a video all about Aegon the Conqueror
and the early history of the Targaryen family
you can click here to watch that and you can
click here for my episode nine video.
Thank you so much for watching. Everybody let's
high five and I'll see you guys tomorrow!